abone ol
Herkese
merhaba ben doktoruna ile Yusuf çocuk ve
ergen psikiyatri ve Psikoterapi Steam
bugün Yankı düşüncelerini yansıtması
çerçevesinde kabul ve adanmışlık
terapisi sıklıkla kullanılan terim ile
aktif penceresinden konuşacağım
bak bakış açısı özellikle son 10 yılda
giderek artan biçimde mesleki
uygulamalarının ve yaşam biçiminin
merkezine yerleşti için size yalnızca
bilgiyle değil yürekten inandıklarım
Lada sesleneceğim Bu arada çok önemli ve
ilham verici bir tema seçildiğini
düşünüyorum o nedenle Emek verenleri
kutlarım
Ben
beyin doktoru Biz gençler Beyin üzerinde
çalışırlar ve bunu söylemek Aslında
bunca yıl o bile Benim kulağıma hala
tuhaf ve iddialı geliyor şu Çünkü beyin
insan bedeninin en karmaşık ve gizemli
organı Tıp dünyasının yapısını
işlevlerini bağlantılarını araştırmakla
bitiremediği bir harikalar diğer Aslında
ve tabi iyiliklerim
bilmediklerimin yanında çok daha az bu
da benim için yaşam boyu bitmeyecek bir
keşif serüveni demektir O nedenle her
zaman heyecanlıyım
beni işlevsel bütünlüğüne zihin adı
veriliyor zihin tüm yaşantıların
orkestrası'nı barındırıyor ve yönetiyor
bu acaba biz zihnimizin nasıl
çalıştığının farkında mıyız orada neler
olup bitiyor
algılar
düşünceler duygular ve bedenimizden bu
duyumlar Türkülerimiz
zihin bütün bu uyaranları birçok bu
bilgiyi nasıl kullanıyor acaba ve bu
ilgiyle bize neler yaptırıyor
orjinal içi çalışma biçimi var
içi modu var diyebilirim bir tanesi göre
ve odaklandığı zamanlarda çalışma içine
bir görevi odaklandığında zihin dikkati
kullanarak bilinçli ve amaçlı işler
yapıyor bir daha çok Şimdi de ve şu anda
oluyor öyle zamanlarda
bir Şimdi de şu anda olduğumuz zaman
geçmişle Gelecekle çok fazla
uğraşmıyoruz pişmanlıklarla kaygılarla
da çok fazla uğraşmıyorsa aslında o
zihnin diğer çalışma modu serbest
gezindiği zamanlardaki çalışma biçimi
Böyle zamanlarda zihin daldan dala
atlıyor Şah geçmişte kah gelecekte
oluyor aslında zihnimizin serbest
gezindiği zamanlarda çok yaratıcı
fikirler üretmesi diğer ürün sanat
eserleri edebi anlatımlar ya icatlar
keşifler iş süreci zihnimizde çevirip
durduğumuz sorunların çözümleri Böyle
Anlarda aklımıza Doğu veriyor aslında
Belirli bir zaman diliminde belirli bir
an içinde zihin ya Bir moda dır Ya diğer
modadır ikisinde birden aynı anda olamaz
O nedenle Aslında biz odaklanmayı başara
bildiğimizde dikkatinizi odaklandığımız
daha olumsuz düşünce ve duygularla başa
çıkabiliyoruz hem de aynı zamanda
zihnimizin serbest gel bu zamanlarda
yarattığı fikirlerin peşine düşer
biliyoruz onların ürünlerini toplaya
biliyoruz fakat
bunu yapmak çok kolay olmuyor şimdi
zihin hiç durmaksızın düşünce üretir bu
kadar çok düşünce üretir ki bazen çok
bunun alırız ve bir suçsa deriz susmaz
nedeni şu zihnin başlıca görevi insanı
korumak ve yaşamda kalmasını sağlamak
Aslında için zihin çok çalışıyor ve hiç
durmuyor yeni bir çalışma diyor ki
günlük ortalama düşünce sayısı 6002
yüzden fazlaymış
Üstelik Zihni kendi haline
bıraktığımızda ürettiği düşüncelerin
yüzde 85'i olumsuz 100'de 95'i de
yineleyici nitelikte yemiş dedim ya illa
bizim
ve
civciv inin peşinde ki amaç bir tavuk
gibi Aman yapma zarar görürsün Aman o
işi bulaşma O çok zor başaramazsa
Üzülürsün ama ne yap yap arkadaşlarına
hoşsunuz dışlanır sana yaşayamazsın diye
dertlenir söylenir durur
bir bu halde bir zihnimizin düşünce
üretimini denetleyebilir miyiz
istediğimiz şeyleri düşünmesini sağlayıp
istemediğimiz de onu susturabilir miyiz
Ne yazık ki çok uygulama verilir bunun
değil uzun dönemde Kısa süre için bile
pek de mümkün olmadığını gösteriyor
Çünkü zihin bildiğini yapar hatta biraz
asidir yap modelleri daha çok yapar size
desem ki nefis sütlü çikolatayı ya da
iter çikolatayı hangisini seviyorsunuz
ya da ve bu beyaz çikolatayı aklınıza
getirmeyin zihniniz sözünüzü dinler
misin Hayır tahminim Ben bunları
söylerken daha hepsi birden Hatta Belki
daha fazlası da zihninize üşümüştür
yetmiyormuş gibi
kendi zihnimizin ürettiği düşüncelerimde
başkalarından aldığımız düşüncelerin
eklendiğini düşünün aile içinde bize
söylenenler burada bize söylenenler
sosyal medyada gördüklerimiz okuyup
izlediklerimiz Başkalarının hakkını
bizim hakkımızda ne düşündüğüne dair
zihnimizin varsayımları bızı
zihnimizdeki gürültü yok kakofoni bir
düşünüyorum Üstelik
birde bunların hepsini birden
inandığımızı düşünün yani zihnimizin
bize ne dediği her şeye inandığımızı
düşünün bu ne kadar zor Aslında aklımız
nasıl karışıyor sinir sistemimiz sürekli
bir tehdit algısı altında nasıl
yoruluyor
yeterince çalışkan değilim Akıllı
değilim güzel değilim Yakışıklı değilim
becerikli değilim böyle giderse
başarısız olacağım ya da dış lan
açacağım ya da yalnız kalacağım gibi
birçok düşünceyi beslediğim izi ve
bunlara inandığımızı düşün
bir süre sonra bakıyoruz ki bu yargılar
bizi tanımlamaya başlamış Yani kim
olduğumuzu tanımlamaya başlamış ve biz
biz tanımların mutlak gerçekler olduğuna
inanmaya başlamış Biz aslında gerçekten
bu tanımlamalar mıyız yani biz gerçekten
zihnimizin bize söyledikleri miyiz Dur
dur düşünmek zor Aslında
düşüncelerimiz sözcüklerden imgelerden
ve seslerden oluşuyor ve biz düşünürken
Evrensel Ve kadim bir tuzağa düşüyoruz
zihnimizden geçenlerin gerçekliğine ve
hem de şimdi şu anda gerçek olduklarını
ve geçerli olduklarına inanma tuzağına
düşüyoruz Böyle zamanlarda endişe korku
ve öfke suçluluk ya da utancı kıskaçları
na düşün veriyoruz bu durumda da
zihnimizi basan Sisten arınıp Duru
biçimde düşünmek çok zor oluyor
bunca düşünce arasında gerçekten kendi
düşüncelerimizi Rüya biliyor muyuz acaba
bizi biz yapan cümlemiz da
Başkalarının düşüncelerine ayırabiliyor
muyuz
işittik lerimizden
öğrenin işimize yarayan ları seçip
ayırabiliyor muyuz
seçtik yerimizi kendinizi geliştirecek
bir şekilde bulunabiliyor
muyuz ve
seçimlerimizin
yapabildiklerimiz in görünmesini ve
işitilmesini sağlayan
biliyormuş Aslında bunu
yapabilsek ve sık sık yapabilsek ne
kadar işimize yarardı değil mi
bu aslında da zihnimizi Duru bir biçimde
izleyebilme becerisine güç İliş adı
veriliyor İngilizce'de uyarlanmış
metakognisyon 13 İliş İnsanın bazen
gizli bazen de farkında bu süper
güçlerinden biri
beceriyi açığa çıkarıp kullanmanın
Yolları var
bu geliştirmenin yolları var Eğer bu
tanımlamayı genişletilirse
zihnimizde bedenimizde ve çevremizde
olup bitenlerin farkında olma Ece
Elimizi geliştirebiliriz Ancak bu
farkındalığın bir özelliği var Bu
dikkatimizi merakla
bilerek ve gönüllü olarak olup bitenlere
odaklayıp yargılamadan fark edebilmek ve
gözlemleyebilmek Yani aslında olup
bitenlerin farkında olduğumuzu da fark
etmek
pek yaygın bilinen adıyla my friends
Türkçesi ile yargısız farkındalık adı
verilen uygulamanın sunduğu yöntemler bu
konudaki başlıca yardımcılarımız bu
zamanlarda aklınıza gelip yüreğimizi
sıkıştıran bir düşünceyi alalım sayım
Sizce bu düşünce Gerçeğin ta kendisi mi
yoksa yalnızca bir olasılık mı
Şimdi şu anda var olan bir çeşit mi
yoksa geçmişe ya da geleceği ait mi
aklınızdakiler yalnızca sözcükler
imgeler ya da seslerden ibaret değil mi
Peki bunlar size şu anda sonuç bir
kötülük yapabilirler mi yoksa kuru
tehditleriyle Kendimiz için yapmak
istediklerinizin işinize yarayacak
niyetlerinizi önüne çıkıp sizi
engelliyorlar mı Hangi düşünceye takılır
sanız sizin için iyi olacağına karar
vermek Aslında elinizde yalnızca
bu sağlıkla alıştırma yapmaya gönüllü
olmak gerekiyor
çok kendimize sorup
farkındalıkla yanıtını
dinleyebileceğimiz sorularımız var
mesela şu anda benim ne ihtiyacım var
yaşamında gerçekten yapmak istediğim
neler var beni heyecanlandıran isteklen
Diren şeyler heveslendiren şeyler
nelerdir
Bir nasıl bir insan olmak istiyorum şu
kimlerle birlikte ne zaman nerede kendim
gibi olabiliyorum
dünyaya başkalarına vermek istediğim
şeyler var mı
Zihnim şu anda nerede de geçmişte mi
gelecek değil mi yoksa şimdi şu anda mı
Zihnim şu anda değilse onu bu ana davet
edip odaklan Sam acaba daha bu daha çok
işine yarar mı
bu zihnimde andan ana beliren düşünceler
inceler yapmak istediklerim açısından
işine yarıyor mu yoksa yalnızca
engellemeye mi yarıyorlar o halde nasıl
düşünsem işime yarardı
İşime yarayan düşüncelerimi seçip
kullanabilir miyim
işime yaramayan düşünceleri de es geçip
onları kendi hallerine
bırakabilir miyim
ben başkalarına Nasıl davranıyorum
kendime Nasıl davranıyorum kendime
başkalarına davrandığım kadar nazik
davranan biliyor muyum acaba
İşte tam böyle soruları yanıtladı ımız
ilham bulduğumuz ilerlemeye
beslendiğimiz anda da zihnimiz yine
devreye girer ama ne yapıyorsun
yapamazsın bu çok ben seni kim dinler
Sen kimsin ki başarısız olursam
utanacaksın sakın Kozan'dan çıkma yeni
şeyler deneme sesini çıkarma sesimi
çıkarırsam ya sorumluluk sana kalır Ya
da sen kötü olursun ne lazım
denemezsen Eğer seni sevdim hiç kimse
yapardım diye teselli bulursun bir de
deneyip yapamadığını düşün zaten ilk
denemede yapamazsam buna başarı mı
diyeceksin işte zihnimiz bi zihin gibi
konuşmaya başladı ve işte yüreğimizi
sıkan korku çekimserlik yine belirdi
yine bütün haşmetiyle bedenimize
çöreklendi
ama aslında bu zihnimizin bir
kandırmacası bilgi kişiler demişler ki
Cesaret korkusuzluk değil korkunun
varlığında korku bu doğru adım atmaya
gönüllü olmaktır burada önemli bir ayrım
var Cesaret göstermekle Gözü Kara
davranmak farklıdır ve farklı sonuçlar
getirir gözü Karalık dürtülerin
etkisinde düşünmeden atmaktır cesaret
ise korkunun elinden nazikçe tutup yine
de ilerlemeye devam etmektir zihniniz ne
derse desin kaydınızın korkularınızın
elinden tutup sizin için iyi
sonuçlanacak adımları bilerek
planlayarak bu farkındalıkla adım atmaya
gönüllü olabilirmisiniz En azından bunu
denemeye Cesaret edebilir misiniz
Biz He cesaretini kuş alırsam Sesin
işitilecek kadar çıkar mı beni işitecek
insanları bulup onlara ulaşabilir miyim
sesini bu hakları dinlemeye ikna
edebilir miyim belki Evet belki Hayır
ama denemezsen iz yanıt kesin Hayırdır
Özen sesiniz başkalarından farklı
çıkabilir seçiminiz aykırı olabilir
beklendiği üzere zihnimiz Böyle
zamanlarda Sesini çok yükseltecektir
seçiminize baktığınızda doğru yerden
geldiğini ve sizi olmak İstediğiniz yere
götüreceğine inanıyor musunuz
inanıyorsanız farkındalık ve
gönüllülükle yine de ilerleyebilir
misiniz
ister beklentilerle uyumlu olsun ister
aykırı olsun seçimler çok işinize
yarayabilir ama tabii hata da
yapabilirsiniz
hatalarınızı geçirdiği üzüntü ve
suçluluk duygularına anlayışla şefkatle
yaklaşıp insanım ben hata yapabilirim O
anda en iyi niyetimle Bana en doğrusu bu
bu gibi görünmüş tüm Gelecek sefer daha
farklı davranan ayım diyebilir misiniz
yaşam hepimiz için zor ve her an
seçimler yaparak ortaya koymak zorunda
kalıyoruz bunları
farkındalığımızı geliştikçe andan ana
dolu dolu yaşayabilir ve geleceğimizi
adım adım kurabiliriz beni dinlediğiniz
için çok teşekkür ederim